the north some 12 month ago and this is  the first of the discoveries I made  myriad of world of what's the  Magisterium controlled only one for  saturates they have been trying to keep  us where they want us  you promise the Magisterium deal control  has real in each table that's right  those are great change coming that worth  letting us all I'm going to give you  something it has a part to play analyst  and a major one we represent a number of  families who have lost children this is  rural  as you can help  she can read their leafy ometer she will  be more valuable to us and any soldier  we have with it our children back you  may have a heart won't have any trouble  with thousands of great hope I'm  stronger  [Music]  Lord Asriel needs to die  there's the time to choose the  [Music]  possibilities no more darkness  [Music]  [Music]  you  you